la réalité c'est que dans notre pays
aujourd'hui on verse une allocation
adulte handicapé pour celles et ceux qui
en situation de handicap ne peuvent pas
travailler ce pas un choix être au rsa
c'est une situation conjoncturelle on
peut pas la comparer avec une situation
de handicap que vous ne choisissez pas
et qui souvent est définitive et
aujourd'hui dans notre pays lorsque vous
êtes en situation de handicap que vous
vivez avec quelqu'un votre allocation
est réduite parce que vous avez le seul
malheur alors que c'est un bonheur de
vivre en couple cette injustice voilà
des années que tout le monde veut la
corriger voilà la quatrième fois que
devant l'assemblée nationale nous
tentons de la corriger et j'étais fier
fière de porter cette proposition de loi
et j'ai eu honte de la position du
gouvernement qui était une position ces
cancers et froide c'est ce que j'ai une
très humain parler de dignité c'est un
vrai beau sujet politique et j'étais
fière vraiment comme beaucoup d'autres
collègues stupéfait de voir que le
gouvernement nous entende et pas il faut
le dire toutes les oppositions étaient
d'accord pour que nous avancions sur ce
sujet seule la république en marche a
refusé que nous laisse sur quoi selon
vous moi j'aime la france qui rassemble
les français j'aime la france qui a été
capable d'abolir la peine de mort qui a
été capable de prononcer le discours du
vel d'hiv de jacques chirac je ne suis
pas celui et la droite française ne doit
pas être celle qui incarne une france
qui est une france triste nous devons
être une france d'espérance ceux qui
demain fera que la droite française
reprendra des couleurs c'est qu'un tel
sera capable de défendre des convictions
et de ne pas se vendre aux uns et aux
autres je pense que ce chemin là nous
pouvons le trouver il nous a permis de
réussir avec jacques chirac avec nicolas
sarkozy il peut nous permettre de
réussir demain